do you think it's possible you said
you're not saying it's necessarily a
good idea to launch a social network
do you think it's possible
today
maybe you can put yourself in those
shoes
to launch a social network
that achieves the scale of a facebook
or twitter or an instagram and maybe
even greater scale absolutely
how do you do it
asking for a friend yeah if i knew i i'd
probably be doing it right now and not
sitting here so
i mean there's a lot of ways to ask this
question one is create a totally new
product market fit create a new market
created something like instagram did
which is like create something kind of
new
or
literally out compete facebook at its
own thing or i'll compete twitter at its
own thing
the only way to compete now if you want
to build a large social network is to
look for the cracks look for the
openings
um
you know
no one competed
i mean no one competed with the core
business of google no one competed with
the core business of microsoft
you don't go at the big guys doing
exactly what they're doing
instagram didn't win quote unquote
because it tried to be
a visual twitter like
we spotted things that either twitter
wasn't going to do or refused to do
images and feed for the longest time
right
or that facebook wasn't doing or not
paying attention to because they were
mostly desktop at the time and we were
purely mobile
purely visual
often there are opportunities sitting
there you just have to
you have to
you have to figure out like uh i think
like there's a strategy book i can't
remember the name but talk about moats
and just like the best place to play
is where your competitor like literally
can't pivot because structurally they're
set up not to be there
and that's where you win um
and what's fascinating is like do you
know how many people are like images
facebook does that twitter does that i
mean how wrong were they really wrong
and these are some of the smartest
people in silicon valley right
but now instagram exists for a while
how is it that snapchat could then exist
makes no sense
like plenty of people would say well
there's facebook no images okay okay
instagram i'll give you that one but
wait now another image-based social
network's going to get really big
and then tick-tock comes along
like
the prior so you asked me is it possible
the only answer and reason i'm answering
yes is because
my prior is that it's happened once
every i don't know three four or five
years
consistently and i can't imagine there's
anything structurally that would change
that
um so that's why i answer that way not
because i know how i just
when you see a pattern you see a pattern
and there's no reason to believe that's
going to stop and it's subtle too
because like you said snapchat and tick
tock they're all doing the same space of
things but there's something
fundamentally different about
like a three second video and a five
second video and a 15 second video in a
one minute video and a one hour video
right like fundamentally different
fundamentally different i mean
i think one of the reasons snapchat
exists is because instagram was so
focused on posting great beautiful
manicured
versions of yourself throughout time
and there was this enormous demand of
like hey i really like this behavior i
love using instagram but
man i just like wish i could share
something going on in my day like
do i really have to put it on my profile
do i really have to make it last forever
do i really
um and that opened up a door it created
a market right and then what's
fascinating is
instagram had an explore page for the
longest time it was image driven right
um
but there's absolutely a behavior where
you open up instagram and you sit on the
explore page all day that is effectively
tick-tock but obviously focused on
videos and it's not like you could just
put the explore page in tik-tok form and
it works it had to be video it had to
have music
these are the hard parts about product
development that are very hard to
predict
but um
they're all versions of the same thing
with varying
if you line them up in a bunch of
dimensions they're just like
kind of on
their different values of the same
dimensions which is like i guess easy to
say in retrospect but like if i were an
entrepreneur going after that area i'd
ask myself like where's the opening
what needs to exist because tiktok
exists now
you